schmeckt irgendwie das hört sich jetzt
sehr komisch an ich finde das schmeckt
irgendwie wieso brot mit so aufstrich
zur frischkäse ob strich und so den
tipps aus in die verschimmelten aber ich
liebe was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei 1 mache ich hatte das
jetzt neue pass mal auf
wir machen das jetzt noch mal von vorne
mit husky job und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe jetzt
irgendwie meine tochter comit diesem bei
ich weiß ja selber das ist falsch ist so
aber irgendwie habe ich gedacht das halt
so mein ding so bei zu sagen und ich
will aber nicht als dumm rüberkommen
deswegen löschen dass sie jetzt aber das
sind schon mal die nicht hinsetzen ich
muss euch nämlich was erzählen und zwar
haben ein kleines problem diebe richtung
iss kaputt wir arbeiten gerade nur mit
tageslicht von draußen von dem was heute
durch das fenster kommt und mit dieser
lampe da oben und das ist halt kein
professionelles video dich deswegen ich
hoffe wir sie trotzdem modus ich habe
mir aber überlegt damit wir noch so eine
etwas hellere atmosphäre haben es etwas
mehr glänzt du einfach mal hier die
kette und dann gleicht sich das
praktisch wieder aus wenn ihr das eis
taut wieder noch nicht gesehen habt dann
heute habe ich folgendes geplant und
zwar kam vor etwas mehr als einem monat
mein video food neuheiten aus dem
letzten monat und es ist schon wieder
100 vergangen weswegen auch wieder neue
sachen raus gekommen sind ich schaue
mich immer bei insta auf der seite von
new jersey ist eigentlich eine echte
seite die post nimmt neuheiten es
neuheiten was auch immer und nicht
verein kaufen ich würde sagen wir
starten direkt mal wenn ihr weitere tat
sehen wollt lassen jetzt schon mal da
und ich stelle euch mal ganz kurz die
sachen vor
wir haben hier pickup bratapfel
zimtgeschmack dh also sowas habe ja
ob das könnte lecker sein in der tat
aber es könnte ja auch nicht lecker sein
wir warten auf als nächstes haben wir
nix kommt nix solchen wartet ja weil ich
keine ahnung was das heißt du bist dann
hier gibt dir das mal kitkat coconut
also da bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf
das habe ich wirklich das ist glaube ich
brandneue paar schießt cookies cream
ich weiß nicht wo logo ist das ein
bekanntes getränk ich kenne es auf jeden
fall
und das ist auch neue moloko cranberry
im letzten tat wollte ich eigentlich
schon diese kekse probieren habe ich
nicht gefunden dafür habe ich die dieses
mal gefunden leibnitz ruby unsere mutter
letzt haben wir krank ships arabischen
also das ist doch ein bisschen scharf
und von funny-frisch donuts also donath
chips anscheinend ich muss sagen extrem
interessante sachen die heute hier dabei
sind beim letzten mal was ich mal
annähernd so interessant ich habe mir
gedacht ich wollte hier mit diesem link
abgängen staaten pickup bratapfel
zimtgeschmack bratapfel ist auch so ein
weihnachtsfilm habe ich früher mal
probiert ich bin zu trotzen
das riecht auch schon so intensiv nach
zimt schmeckt extrem weinerlich
weihnachtlich natürlich liegt auch an
der jahreszeit jetzt versucht jeder
irgendwas zu kreieren was nach
weihnachten schmeckt und das haben die
meiner meinung nach gut geschafft müsste
ich jetzt punkte geben wer ist auf jeden
fall in neun von zehn aber muss ich ja
zum glück nicht deswegen spielen wir
erstmal direkt nach mit moko cranberry
ich bin sehr gespannt weil ich auch
früher des öfteren mal die wie wir es
doch mal die normale variante du trinkst
doch immer ich mal die mittel global und
die matte ja genau das habe ich auch
schon mal probiert das finde ich nicht
das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
wow das bleibt so an den zähnen kleben
so das ist so richtig
nachdem markus ist nicht meins also zum
nachspielen in ordnung aber würde ich
mir jetzt niemals privat kauft so ach so
und ich blende euch hier natürlich auch
dann immer das foto ein von der seite
fotos germany
schöne grüße auf wieder an dieser stelle
damit ihr seht damit ihr seht dass es
wirklich aktuell ist ich muss auch sagen
dein letztes mal hatte ich das problem
das ich in den supermarkt gegangen bin
und überhaupt keine neuen sachen
gefunden habe einfach weil ist so
unübersichtlich war aber hier bei uns in
dem supermarkt gab es irgendwie voll
viel und ich habe es auch richtig
schnell gefunden weil für die leute hier
ist auch interessiert da steht dann
immer unten auf dem preisschild so fett
neue drauf das ist heute noch zu sagen
und so den chips aus um die verschimmelt
sind aber ich liebe schimmel sowie
meinig hat das nein ich weiß nicht mehr
so was ist und spaß nun von seen direkt
manchmal auch partys liegen daher diese
vasari kügelchen die finde ich gar nicht
mal so schlecht natürlich jetzt auch
nicht so nice aber diese chips kann ich
mir gar nicht vorstellen dass das jemand
gerne ist durchgefallen aussehen 0
geschmack 0
als nächstes haben wir hier
ich weiß ich sollte es jetzt schon
machen da habe ich mich am meisten auf
gefreut komme ich dachte erst dass die
verpackung hier durchsichtig ist und man
da rein gucken kann das wäre schon geil
jetzt schauen wir mal ob die kitkat
wirklich so aussehen wie auf der
verpackung kitkat test auf delicious
coconut also kokosnuss ist es raus und
du sagst ob es gut aussieht weil hinten
das ist schwarz es sieht schon mega gau
sieht gut aus
weißt du dass meine vermutung ist die
wurden ganz klar geeignet riecht
intensiv nachbarn von ganz genau
hingehört zu messen
raffaello kann man noch essen raffaello
als tafel schokolade oder ich muss sagen
eigentlich bin ich nämlich gar nicht so
ein baum defendo früher es gab nichts
was ich mehr gehasst habe als bounty das
konnte ich wirklich nicht
runterschlucken da wird mir schlecht von
ich habe es immer wieder versucht heute
ist es so eine sache
es geht aber ich hab sogar mehr geholt
weil ich dachte dass der bock aufbau
tief also ich hab hier noch nie selber
gekauft sagen wir mal so beim letzten
mal weißt du noch hatte ich red bull
spekulatius es gibt immer neue sachen
das ist faszinierend also das sind
eigentlich so videos die mir viel spaß
bereitet machen wir weiter
wir haben hershey's cookies und krieg
hier muss ich sagen das habe ich auf
keiner seite gesehen das hat mich
angelächelt unterstand ganz dick jetzt
neue traum also auf dem preisschild
vorne und es sieht so ein bisschen aus
wie oreo deswegen keine ahnung ihr könnt
ja sehr gemein die kommentare schreiben
falls ihr das kind gegen die bisschen
schwierig auszumachen
ach so
das ist praktisch wieder eine art kleine
tafel schokolade und man einzelne
schokoladen abbrechen kann
schmeckt 1 zu 1 mio aber probleme ein
nun ja denn du kannst ja abrechnung
probiert immer das recht gut weg wie
oreo nur als tafel schokolade und ich
muss sagen orio an sich es sich
überhaupt nicht gerne
das stimmt allerdings nicht könnte wäre
es nicht schon halt mit dem typischen
geschmack von weißer schokolade
egal also hier ich würde zehn von zehn
geben aber muss ich damit wir sie jetzt
chronologisch schlau machen was man hier
die neben extremen nix mit max warum ist
noch staub dran
die standen da wahrscheinlich schon sehr
lange wollte keiner haben kein gutes
zeichen
sie sehen aus wie erdnüsse so ein
bisschen die große erdnüsse ich muss
sagen schmecken auf jeden fall gut ich
finde die originalen besser die spenden
einfach so wie das original nur extrem
gesalzen also man schmeckt hier richtig
das salz raus ob das gut ist für die
leute die sagen natürlich für mich
ehrlich das ist einzig das muss man
mögen und glaubt einen firewire gut mehr
weil ich da von uns auch nicht essen
mir wird gleich wahrscheinlich
unterschrift das ist immer der nachteil
bei diesen
des videos natürlich ist es auf der
einen seite cool alle denken immer auch
den job ist ja so easy in manchen videos
musst du einfach nur essen probieren
herzlich immer leichter an als es ist
ich mein man muss es ja auch alles essen
dazu noch irgendwie scheiße labern damit
die leute gerne anschauen
ich will mich nicht mehr das würde ich
nicht sagen doch wieso ist doch so das
war's also ich sagte schon dass meine
ehrliche meinung baualter das ist ja
noch mal das sieht ja wirklich klink aus
wird so ein naja natürlich probieren
erst nur den rand mit himbeer abruf galt
es nicht so gut schmeckt gegend wurde
das hört sich jetzt sehr komisch an ich
finde das schmeckt irgendwie wieso brot
mit so aus strich so frischkäse
aufstrich nein spaß also von der davon
weil es so leicht mit kühlen geschmack
hat macht es keinen sinn doch ich finde
dass das meint das ist ganz komisch hier
also hat mich jetzt nicht ganz überzeugt
aber die anschlüsse die erdnuss karamell
style süß und salzig donuts von
funny-frisch weil du ein karamell fällen
bis ich bin echt
warum ich die ja das kann das schon
jetzt schon wieder genug gibt was ist
denn damit passiert sehen die alle so
aus also ich bin ultra gespannt hast du
dich schon mal gesehen
ne ich auch nicht weil du weißt doch
warum die sind neu die schmecken 101 ps
philips mit ein bisschen komischen
beigeschmack
und das schmeckt zu 100 prozent aber
nicht nachkommen also da gibt es bessere
produkte von funny-frisch durchgefallen
wir hatten mal kurz fest meines
erachtens gewinner heute ist ganz klar
dieser hershey's cookies cream riegel
oder tafel schokolade wie man es auch
immer nennen möchte und die kitkat
kokona lettischen ihr heute auch
instagram heissig alex wie wenn ihr
irgendwas davon nach kaufte schickt man
das gerne in star schreibt eure meinung
dazu interessiert mich immer sehr erfolg
mit auch gerne und das war s für
lichtsparte daumen nach oben pressen und
ich bin so
sich jetzt hinter mir beim er würde
jetzt auch schaffen wir sehen uns morgen
um 19 uhr ja ja wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder und ich denke irgendwie
ein bisschen dicker bin ich geworden
durch das ersten jetzt halt rein
[Gelächter]